the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's let's walk through it we have
three lists l1 is equal to R a l2 is
equal to me L 3 is equal to dou L 4 is
equal to let's just do what is what it
says here L 1 plus L 2 so it's going to
be the list array me me now extend is
going to mutate the list so that means L
3 is going to be extended by whatever L
4 is so L 3 is going to be okay what did
it have originally it had do doh and
then it's going to be extended by all of
the elements inside L 4 which is Ray me
like that
and once I've mutated it the old version
of L 3 is gone right this is the this is
the L 3 down here that I'm going to work
with L 3 dot sort is going to start
alphabetically so that's Doh me ray yep
and sort also mutates the list so the
old version of the list I have is gone
del is going to also mutate the list so
it's going to look in l3
look at index 0 and it's going to delete
that that it's going to delete that
element so it's going to mutate L 3 and
it's going to be me ray ok and once
again I've mutated the list so the old
version is gone and lastly this is a
tricky part I'm going to append to my
current l3 which looks like this another
list so 2 L 3 I'm appending another list
so this is going to be the list
okay so me ray and then the list fella
is the answer which is red no sorry
blue good you got me scared okay perfect
so if you didn't get this I would
suggest you go through the Python tutor
or you just trace it out by hand just
like I just did and hopefully it'll be
sort of a parent the more the more
exercises you do with lists what exactly
is going on okay